[Music]
if you don't get physically ill
seeing your first rough cut something's
wrong
you always think you're not gonna get
physically ill but you do
now if you're taking this class you
should have the bravery
and ignorance of wanting to get
something done
people think it's good editing if you
can see it
good editing is something else too where
you don't see it
sometimes you think something is
dreadfully wrong and later and you look
it in the context of a cut
might work well in the case of
production design when you take it to
casino
the excess is what the film's about the
manic nature of it
splashiness of the whole thing we knew
that it had a certain quality to it
that's contrasted later with the
confrontations between joe pesci and bob
de niro just the two of them in the
desert
arguing you feel the change there's
nothing there
if the actors want to take a scene a
certain place i'll go with them there
there are things i know don't work
immediately but you shoot it because
it's a process
if you had the time on set i like to
tell the actors to
try anything have the time to fail just
go ahead try this try that
you need that freedom you need to give
them that freedom
[Music]
well of course when i was younger you
didn't have cameras and that sort of
thing was too expensive
this world of moviemaking
where these miraculous images and
stories came from
really felt very distant i had a teacher
he was the one to give me the confidence
to become a filmmaker to come from this
other world and suddenly be able to
express myself
if the machinery of it all seems too big
and scary and overwhelming
it's great you wake up in the morning
and you do it anyway
you have to learn it yourself you have
to learn it going through that process
that's the greatest thing any teacher
could give a student the confidence and
the inspiration
to make you think well you know it's
crazy but maybe i can do it
now it's time to get to work i'm martin
scorsese and
this is my master class
you